i have a duty it's one i take very
seriously to keep scotland as safe as
possible
i'm sure andy burnham feels that same
sense of duty
towards people in the greater manchester
area
um i have always gone well with andy
burnham if he wants a
grown-up conversation he only has to
pick up the phone but if
as i suspect might be the case this is
more about generating a spat with me as
part of some
positioning in a labour leadership
contest of the future then i'm not
interested
well nicolas sturgeon was speaking uh
around the time she had her
second dose of coronavirus well let's go
to sky's tom parmenter who
is in manchester uh why is andy burnham
so cross
tom is it just posturing
well it has certainly turned into a bit
of a political spat this they both of
course have something of a common foe
the labour mayor here in the northwest
of england
and the snp government in edinburgh
of course their common foe is the
conservative westminster government but
they are turning on
each other in this public health row
that has escalated into something of a
political spat
the advice not to travel
uh to these parts of the northwest of
england
uh has been around for a while initially
applicable to bolton and blackburn with
darwin due to their
high case rates of the delta variants
and that now
from today is expanded to manchester
and salford here in greater manchester
so uh it is
something that has escalated beyond that
public health
uh new set of rules implemented by the
scottish government and
andy burnham uh we'll be talking about
that more today he has previously
uh said that the lack of communication
is one of the big problems that he has
with
what they have done it's straightforward
arrogance he said to say that scottish
ministers
shouldn't deign to speak to english
mayors
and of course this is disruptive for
businesses who are reliant on visitors
between
the northwest of england and scotland
and of course people whose holiday plans
may have changed
many many times over the course last few
months maybe they've
scrapped in overseas or they decided to
take a uk break a
walking holiday in the highlands or
another remote part of scotland and
if they were to follow the rules those
holidays now if they are living in
manchester salford
and of course bolton and blackburn with
darwin those holidays should not
be taking place we'll be hearing more
from the mayor of greater manchester
through the course of the morning but
it's certainly a personal um row as we
heard from nicolas sturgeon there
accusing andy burnham of posturing in
his uh
her her perception that it is his case
to be
the national labor leader and that's why
he's coming out so strong on this